madam chair members of the commission
i'd be willing to answer any questions
directly related to the tentative track
map application and the planned unit
development application before you today
you want to address any of the concerns
from the audience
or you want specific
uh well i heard many concerns i'm not
exactly sure madam chair which which
concerns you would like me to uh to
answer
okay how about um rob i'm gonna ask if
you'll help me address some of the
concerns right one of the concerns was
whether this is properly before the
board and it is properly before the
board um it's ripe for decision there's
no gag order or injunction from a court
they fought an application and
it's probably before you to consider
as far as the road is concerned the
settlement agreement only applies to
major projects for increased density and
of course it's not a major project and
it's not seeking increased density but
the the density satisfies the
density standard for the ru zoning
district
the there's a can you know they have to
provide
paid legal access before the final map
records because if the map records you
know there's a lot available for sale it
has to have a road to it
so so that applies before the final map
records but they don't have to provide
paid legal access at this point
of the application process
any other questions
so me i'm concerned about the fire i
know how hard it is with volunteer fire
departments the um it does say that
they'll have to comply with emergency
access um with the fire code so that
assumes that
our code says it has to be paid to have
proper access to get there right
they'll have to do a traffic study in
compliance and provide paved legal
access so it won't be the existing mine
hall road that will be there servicing
this property it would be a different
road that complies with the traffic
study
and it would be a paid legal access to
the property and so let me um and i
don't know who the and maybe the right
person isn't here for me to ask on the
um
the volunteer fire department is that
one that falls under clark county's rule
they're not separate like moapa right
no the um
the condition is put in by um fire
prevention building and fire prevention
however
there are standards and i i can let
antonio jump in but there are standards
that the county has for the roadways for
paving for width for grade all of that
sort of thing and they would
again they would have to um as noted
they would have to demonstrate paid
legal access and paid legal access would
have to comply with our standards they'd
also have to comply with um
they'd have to get the paid legal access
from blm and they would have to get
n-dot approval to be able to access 159
okay
antonio anything
i think nancy covered it um they again
they will have to get a grant
and uh they will have to get concurrence
from ndot since 159 is
uh n dot
um an n not highway
our minimum access requirements are 32
feet it has to be paved um
because they are in the non-attainment
pm10 area so
they will have to comply and fire should
not have an issue getting
to that parcel
okay i just have one more question and
so i'm trying to wear my water authority
hat and my health district hats
so we are not at the health district um
and at least at the water it's already
not approving any septic
um
systems neighborhoods whatsoever um
because we're trying to stay on top of
that so they would have to comply
with all of the full you
needed correct
well if that's a health district
regulation then they'll have to comply
with the health district regulations
that apply at the time that the final
map records okay yeah we're just at the
health district we've not been approving
any more septics
just because of the nitrates and the
nitrate packages so okay
commissioners anybody else have
questions commissioner gibson thank you
i guess the public works uh what is the
nearest source of water that would serve
this number of homes
oh i might need help with rob i want to
say it's close to hualapai blue diamond
and hualapai
oh yes that's my understanding i think
it's blue diamond wildfire miles
miles away right
and is there
so so are there public
roads and streets
all the way from that source of water
that would enable
service right to the
the neighborhood
or are there
the easements we're talking about are
they across blm property
and they've not have they been applied
for and has the blm expressed any intent
with respect to those easements
well from hualapai there's the state
highways first of all to get to that
property and then after this uh if it's
approved and after this uh application
then it would be incumbent upon
the applicant to to contact blm and
obtain whatever easements or right of
ways required by the blm to be able to
provide those utilities to the
property
now whether they have uh began that
process or not i don't know they're
probably waiting to see whether or not
this tentative map is this application
is approved
well
that is a question i'd like the
applicant to respond to is that an
application that's been filed with a blm
have you done anything in respect of the
provision of utility services to the to
the
the applicant currently has on file with
the blm a right-of-way application for a
roadway proposed coming from the
easterly direction connecting state
route 160 for this specific
application as rob pointed out we would
file
a new application for
right-of-way a grant
providing access for vehicular traffic
as well as infrastructure
across blm properties connecting to this
applicant's property
and all of that would be directed to 159
state road
159 as opposed to 160 is that the plan
that is the plan for this application
that is correct
anybody else have any comments or
questions
okay um
so i guess i'd entertain a motion
um to follow staff's recommendations if
there's no more questions commissioner
jones
madam chair uh i need to make a
disclosure
uh in january 2019 after taking office i
requested an advisory opinion from the
nevada ethics commission regarding
whether i was precluded from voting on
zoning matters involving the applicant
gypsum resources llc given my prior pro
bono legal representation of save
redrock in litigation brought by clark
county concerning a prior major projects
application based upon the information
that i provided to the ethics commission
regarding my prior representation of say
redrock the ethics commission opined
that i should comply with the disclosure
requirements of nrs 281 a
.421 d for a period of one year but that
abstention
was not required to the contrary the
ethics commission emphasized that under
nrs 281a 0.424
there is an expressed legal presumption
against abstention and that abstention
would divest my constituents in district
f of my vote on matters of importance to
them
although more than two and a half years
has passed since the ethics comm
opinion and all the present gypsum
zoning applications were not brought
onto the major projects process that was
the subject of my prior representation
of say redrock i am nevertheless hereby
disclosing that i previously represented
save redrock in matters relating to
gypsum's major projects application
including in litigation brought by clark
county in which gypsum was named a party
and which was dismissed by all parties
in november 2018
in 2019 gypsum filed a lawsuit against
clark county in which gypsum makes
allegations of impropriety against me
including that i have shown personal
animus towards mr jim rhodes as
evidenced by amongst other things a
tongue-in-cheek social media post from
october 31st 2018
and that i failed to disclose all
relevant information to the ethics
commission given that the ethics
commission opinion principally related
to gypsum's major projects applications
including prior requested waivers and
the intervening lawsuit i would like to
hear the district attorney's position as
to whether i'm required to abstain from
voting on agenda items 17 and 18.
okay uh rob it's the district attorney's
opinion that you may vote on this and
that you do not need to abstain on this
these applications
thank you mr warhola
okay any other comments or questions can
i just uh clarify because i don't
remember by acid this is
this is no increased density this is um
what it's um zoned for currently right
that's correct and and what is that one
are you zoning which is a one unit for
every two acres okay just wanted to make
sure forgot if i asked it
okay uh can we share sega
commissioner bloom
yes um i'm gonna vote in favor of this
just because it's my understanding that
they comply with the zoning but it
sounds to me like there's so many issues
going forward that i'm not really
addressed at this point that i don't see
how they could ever do it water and
everything else but
very basic concept of the land use
matches what they've asked for then i
think at this point we have to vote
in favor
okay commissioner miller
i i don't know if commissioner jones
intends to vote on this and follow the
district attorney's recommendation it
sounds like maybe he will but
it's obviously his district we're going
to do some redistricting my district's
adjacent to that
i'm more than happy to make the motion
for approval uh
in the absence of
mr jones not
make an emotion
okay
uh
go ahead redrock's important to
everybody so
uh go ahead commissioner miller sure
i'll move for approval uh
as outlined in staff report
okay commissioner miller has uh made a
motion for approval any further
discussion
i have one other question yep um of our
lawyer
we recognize that there is pending
litigation there's been a concern
expressed by some that
there are there could be or there are
issues proceeding with this uh
application and i take and taking action
on it
please uh respond to that weep
right there's no gag order from the
court there's no injunction
uh the
matter being litigated is completely
different it has to do with a
major project application and the timing
of a right-of-way that
fell under the settlement agreement uh
to the east which is to 160. none of
those issues are currently
before you the issue here is completely
different this has to do with their
existing ru zoning
uh they're proposing access from a
different location that comply with the
zoning and and all the requirements
it's just not an issue that's before the
court like i said it's an application
that's before you
um and like i said there's no gag order
no injunction nothing no order from the
court that prohibits us from considering
this matter so it's properly before you
thank you
i'll bring up i guess that's one issue
that was raised the red rock overlays
district it's
it's our position that the
red rock beverly district
the purpose of that is to preserve the
natural setting
and certainly that's not the case here
because this is clearly the almost or
all of the property is a mining property
it's been mined or will be mined
and so really there's no natural setting
to preserve so it's our position my
office's position the district
attorney's office position
that the red rock overlay district does
not apply to this these applications
and that's our opinion that that issue
is really not before you that's really
our opinion on it we've researched the
issue and we believe it's not um
doesn't really apply to this property
because it's been mine the property's
been mine there's no natural setting to
preserve but that's our that's our
position on the matter
so i guess will they have to come back
before us that any if they make any
substantial changes
they would have to come back and start
over correct right if the channel map
the proposed application has significant
changes then i'll have to come back and
submit another application
so i thought
okay there's a motion on the floor by
commissioner miller
any further discussion
cnn please cast your vote
and that motion passes next item please